coming up next week in Brussels energy
labeling the effects of caffeine and
Europe gears up to do battle in football
okay to the agenda what is your grind
here for the types of household products
you buy for your home is it cost design
or perhaps energy efficiency whether
it's washing machines dishwashers and
TVs the types of electrical appliances
we buyer to use in our homes all come
with an energy efficiency rating the
more efficient a product the less it
costs you to use the longer it can last
but in an effort to improve energy
efficiency by twenty-five percent by
2020 and to simplify EU wants to go back
to the old rating system of a 2g and set
up an eu-wide product database mapa from
the industry trade committee vote on a
draft report on Tuesday certain energy
drinks claim to give you wings but is
that misleading need a pick-me-up energy
drinks but also sugary drinks that claim
to give you greater alertness and
physical endurance to get you through
the day but Emmy peas are calling for
that labeling to be done away with they
say is irresponsible the companies claim
that the caffeine put into their
products create better concentration the
objection then as cross-party support
will be debated on Tuesday with a vote
on Wednesday and now for the news in
brief on Tuesday morning the president
of the Eurogroup Durham dizer bloom will
be at the Parliament to discuss economic
governance alongside the president of
the economic and financial affairs
council and the Dutch finance minister
at the economic and Monetary Affairs
Committee a final trial of between
Parliament and the EU council to hash
out an agreement to ban it deep sea
fishing in EU waters beyond 800 metres
takes place on Tuesday and finally on
Friday if you're a football fan two
words euro 2016 it all kicks off on
Friday as house France take on Romania
at the stand of France in Paris it's the
first time since 1998 in France won the
World Cup that they'll be hosting an
international football competition it
also comes from seven months after
multiple terror attacks in Paris
the stadium itself been one of the
targets enhance security is expected at
all host city venues but many see the
heroes as a moment for unity and healing
so who's your pick for the crown will it
be the current holders Spain or do you
think France have home advantage and
that's all of this gender take care and
come on england